you seem calmer than i expected you'd be
i got you something let me open it for
you
you have to go to washington i told you
i'm turning it down
i was being selfish you put your whole
life on hold for me the very least i can
do is try to return the favor
are you sure about this we can make it
work
i'll go visit you then you come visit me
then i go visit you again and then we
make out in the lincoln bedroom and the
jefferson memorial and
the supreme court gallery we'll do it
all over washington
thank you
why did you get a washington monument
figurine at midnight on a tuesday
from my office i have like 50 of them
right
the recount's over they just called the
race oh god
it's still 21 votes
but you won
you won leslie you won by 21 votes
it's confirmed it's over you won
that was really sneaky and i know i
couldn't resist
hello jacob ah ames
what are you doing here why aren't you
out looking for the belt you and i both
know the belt never left the precinct i
don't know that nobody knows that i kept
thinking how did anyone swap my key
and then it hit me they didn't they
swapped the safe
one of the handmaids i'm assuming fake
charles took my safe
and then of amy deposited a look-alike
what did you give fake charles so he'd
help you nothing in fact he gave me
something the power of financial freedom
i invested in a pyramid scheme it's no
time to go into it right now okay
so while we all tried to figure out who
had the real key fake charles broke into
the safe removed the tracker and led
terry in the whole squad on a wild goose
chase
my only question is which box is the
belt in well
good luck figuring it out because the
clock is tick tick tocking
it's that one no the dust pattern on top
doesn't match its neighbors
you see jake i'm always gonna be one
step ahead of you you've lost the
ability to surprise me
you're just plain boring again weird
take on our very loving relationship and
it's midnight so i guess i'm an amazing
human slash genius
yeah although you might want to read the
inscription on that their belt
why oh no what does it say
amy santiago will you marry me
surprise
i'm so confused i don't know what's
happening right now i'm so confused i
don't know what's happening right now
title your sex tape
oh my god i'm shaking i'm definitely
gonna cry
title of your sex tape wait is this
really happening
is this part of the heist if this is
part of the heist i will dump you so
hard no please look it's really
happening okay
it's not part of the heist i promise
this is where you are
i love how beautiful you are i love your
face and i love your butt
i should have written this down first no
no it's okay go on
i love how much you pretend to like die
hard i like the second one
you don't have to okay yeah you're kind
and you're
funny and you're the best person i know
and
the best detective
also for reals i love your butt i love
yours too gross
amy santiago will you marry me
jake peralta i will marry you
i love you so much hey jerkos this
little [ __ ] escaped so that ought to
teach did you just mm-hmm
and did you see
[Applause]
[Music]
when streams are ripe and swelled with
rain ladies and gentlemen
we are gathered here today to marry
andrew
maxwell dwyer and april roberta ludgate
i guess i kind of hate most things
but i never really seem to hate you
so i want to spend the rest of my life
with you is that cool
yes is it my turn
yes april you're the most awesome person
i have ever known in my entire life i
vow to protect you
from danger i don't care if i have to
fight an ultimate fighter
or a bear or him your mom
i would take him down i'm getting mad
right now even thinking about it i'm
telling you it's okay
i want to spend the rest of my life
every minute with you
and i'm the luckiest man in the galaxy
you left then a month later you took
terry with you
yeah well we needed a mindless fact
totem and he's the best there is
hey man then you took april
i didn't want her to go as she had
become one of my closest
workplace acquaintances but your offer
was too good to pass up so
i didn't try to stop her and tom left to
run his business donna left to run hers
one day i looked up just didn't
recognize anyone
so i made a decision an
unthinkable decision
hey well my my my do my eyes deceive me
is that ron swanson
hello leslie hello april larry
uh it's terry now okay as luck would
have it oh
did you talk to randy about the vote
tell the northeast that we need to put
pressure on them or else we're gonna be
waiting for everyone i'm tired of
waiting on them okay
sorry this is a crazy day so what's up
with you you big lug
nothing important just thought you might
want to have lunch
uh tomorrow i would love to it's been
too long
jj's diner 12 30. excellent see you then
okay
so randy says the house is voting
tomorrow and they need us in washington
to prep
oh my god really okay get us the first
flight out of here and grab the missouri
files meet me at my car
hey babe i got to go to washington can
you pick up the kids
oh oh no ron i stood you up for lunch
you did yes i waited for a while but it
was pretty easy to figure out what had
happened
your life seemed pretty hectic is that
the rest of the story that i stood you
up
you were going to ask me something
that's why you wanted to have lunch
ron you were going i was going to ask
you for a job
in the federal government just saying it
out loud feels dirty
at least once a year i like to bring in
some of my kevin's
famous chili the trick is
to undercook the onions everybody
is going to get to know each other in
the pot
i'm serious about this stuff i'm up the
night before
pressing garlic and dicing whole
tomatoes
i toast my own ancho chilis
it's a recipe passed down from malone's
for generations
it's probably the thing i do best
hey keep an eye on her all right okay
we'll do bye
hey hey how's it going good especially
after i took all your money in poker
yeah oh
hey uh can i talk about something about
when you want to give me more of your
money
did you want to do that now we can go
inside i'm feeling kind of good tonight
i was just um
i'm in love with you what
i'm really sorry if that's weird for you
to hear but i need you to
hear it
probably not good timing i know that i
just what are you doing
what do you expect me to say to that
i just need you to know
once
well i um
i
i can't no
you have no idea don't do that
what your friendship needs to be come on
i don't want to do that
i want to be more than that
i can't
i'm really sorry
if you misinterpreted things
it's probably my fault
not your fault i'm sorry i
misinterpreted uh our friendship
you